retrouvez gare de morges oh oui pourrait
dire de mover d'abord complètement
entièrement d'accord avec signer avec
mes d'ailleurs et que ça fait vraiment
triste de voir la nouvelle génération là
les jours nina jeunesse là les petits
lycéens de merde qui viennent de dire
ouais nous les valeurs morales et tout
quand même pour la respecter et quand
même moche oui c'est tout c'est
vachement sérieux s'habillant punk ça
sous les cheveux sur la tête envoie en
gros c'est aussi ça le dire que
s'associent cela est logique
ouais moi je lis pas charlie hebdo mais
mes parents ils ne lisent alors ça veut
dire que l'expression fils de cons ça
veut plus rien dire maintenant ça on va
dire parents de comp doublé contre la
liberté d'expression se rappelle bien
rigolé moi la liberté d'expression j'ai
jamais été pour et le pluralisme je sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire c'est monde
intellectuel m minutes et les fachos
comme ça ça fait cent ans que milan qui
nous crache à la guérison des crasses au
fait parce qu'ils ont la liberté
d'expression et puis que nous on dit
peace and love et tous nous il faut
compter de ce jour là les mecs comme
charlie hebdo qui crèvent en ce moment
parce que ils ont ils fassent que parce
que voilà et nous y voilà la jeunesse et
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu parce qu'il ya
des connards qui vote à gauche et qui
vont les procès à charlie hebdo parce
qu'on a vu leurs crânes où il s'était
même pas la leur laissera pas été facile
et où elle est à mon sens la charia doit
être créé pour moi le seul journal de ma
vie qui les fait rire c'était charrier
de maintenant toutes les semaines tous
les mois je dois faire un journal les
gens ne se trouverait plus jamais un qui
me fera marais voilà voilà pourquoi
aimer je fais partie des connards doit
racheter parité semaine en plus
d'acheter que le foie gras